the humble bumblebee has a surprisingly  flexible brain they can come up with the  most efficient solution to receive a  reward rather than simply mimicking what  they see others do these were taught to  move a ball to the center of a platform  if successful they got a sugary treats  they were taught by other bees by fake  bees held by scientists or by invisible  ghost bees actually a magnet but they  didn't learn so well from the ghost bees  real bees were better teachers rather  than mimicking the conditions they were  shown bees went off-script to solve  problems the demonstrations they learn  from all involved yellow balls  this ball is black not yellow but the  bee still chooses it as the closest ball  to the center she knows she doesn't need  a yellow ball specifically any ball will  do to solve the problem this kind of  cognitive flexibility is previously  unknown in insects clever girls  [Music]  you